am i having regrets it's a little weird
the flipping doesn't oh
hi i'm alexis and if you know anything
about my cooking style you know i love
using ingredient in as many ways as
possible it cuts down on food waste and
it's better for your budget so today my
friends betsy and katie have challenged
me to make a three-course meal using
only five ingredients i don't know what
they are but i think i'm excited i'm
ready
i'm so scared for you
love this okay initial thoughts i'm like
these are all ingredients i have at home
dessert is gonna be weird for my
surprise ingredients i have corn cereal
chickpeas shrimp lemons and carrots so i
know at home you've got a pantry so we
are gonna give you access to a few
pantry staples to help you a little bit
along the way and what are those pantry
staples
thanks guys for my pantry staples i have
flour olive oil sugar salt and garlic
powder i really felt so excited seeing
these surprise ingredients and i was
like i can totally do this in my sleep
but i really just kind of blacked out
and seemed to forget that i won't have a
full pantry i'm gonna brainstorm the
shrimp shells could be made into like
shrimp stock carrot tops could be like a
chimichurri with the chickpeas i can
make aquafaba wait do i get
any kitchen tool i want for this
absolutely yeah score whenever i do chef
out of water i have whatever ingredients
i want but a weird cooking tool so maybe
this will be
easier
with whatever i do i want to make sure
it's like properly appetizer main course
dessert okay i have a plan i don't know
how i feel about the plan but i have one
and uh we'll see what happens i'm so
nervous i don't know what i'm doing is
this harder than chef out of water this
is definitely harder so maybe this will
be easier i'm gonna start with dessert
i'm just going to do really simple
one-to-one sugar and water betsy and
katie told me i could use water very
generous of them it's making my life a
lot easier normally i would blanch the
lemons before but i'm going to skip that
today because there's a lot to do when
you're making a simple syrup you want
the sugar to completely dissolve and
come to a boil so it becomes like that
nice syrupy mixture my simple syrup's
boiling i'm just gonna pop the lemons in
and let them go for five to ten minutes
i'm gonna move on to my streusel i would
love some butter right now but um you
know that's part of the challenge i also
don't really have one of these in mine
so i'm really just winging it i'm gonna
add some sugar and some salt nice
balance of flavors there i'm gonna add a
little bit of the infused simple syrup
how are you feeling how are you feeling
i don't know this is weird maybe i need
more sugar let's see
i mean this tastes pretty good i thought
i'd add some olive oil because i don't
have the fat from the butter i don't
want it to taste like olive oil though
so i think i just need to be like pretty
sparing i feel like i'm a kid like in
the pantry just like kind of like
grabbing things and being like does this
work i'm hoping that some of this kind
of like clumps together like a little
cereal cluster if this works i will be
truly truly truly shocked and very
impressed with myself my lemons are done
though i think i'm gonna pop the lemons
on a sheet pan and then pop them both in
the oven and then move on to the next
part the last component of my dessert is
to make a meringue usually to do this
you would use egg whites but obviously i
don't have any eggs but i do have
chickpeas in vegan baking it's really
popular to use aquafaba for meringues
for even for savory dishes i've never
done it before we'll see what happens
when i try
so to do this i'm just going to pour the
liquid in i just it's hard to believe
that this works save these for later all
right just whisk
so it actually looks kind of like egg
whites if i was making meringue i would
start adding the sugar in this case i'm
going to use the infused lemon simple
syrup really bringing it home
low waste guys and i hope that works how
you feeling
it looks like it's kind of working
so fine soft beaks just gonna give it a
little taste
um i'm not sure the simple syrup is
really doing its job so i'm gonna do two
things i'm gonna add regular granulated
sugar and some lemon zest which i think
are really gonna bring that the flavors
of meringue whipped cream home and we
get to use lemon in another way win-win
let's see if this helps
nice it's a little weird
wow i feel a lot of things we'll start
with the bad the lemons didn't quite
turn out the way i expected i'm gonna
rectify it by just chopping them up the
corn flakes look amazing maybe i should
try some
we're going to start with crumble and
then i think creamy and then some lemon
and i'm just going to repeat that again
double layer
so
cute i think this is incredibly charming
i'm gonna pop them in the fridge move on
to the next course now i'm gonna make my
appetizer i really don't have a plan for
this to start i'm gonna add some corn
flakes
i have an idea to add the chickpeas to
the corn flakes and then pulse it all
together follow your gut but my gut
isn't telling me anything it looks kind
of like chickpea flour which is actually
a really good sign that's what i want i
mean i don't really know what i want but
i think this is what i want now i'm
gonna add some salt i think this can be
like pretty generous on the salt and
some garlic powder because that's the
only other seasoning i have some olive
oil and then i thought i would add some
aquafaba to have it stick together a
little bit i wanted to be like pancake
batter so i think i'm gonna add some
water confidence is just not very high
right now i think before i add more
water i'm gonna do a test pancake i'm
gonna use olive oil if i was at home i'd
probably use an oil with a higher smoke
point
i don't have any cooking time because
this isn't a real recipe and i've never
done it before so i'm just gonna wait to
see what happens the flipping doesn't
oh
i didn't put flour duh i'm gonna add
some carrots and some flour and try
again i really believe that this is
gonna work i think a few tablespoons of
flour it's really about getting that
right texture of like making sure it
holds together enough and also that it's
loose enough to spread look at that okay
cute it looks like the sides are kind of
firming up so let's take a look
oh
that looks gorgeous this is a fritter a
confidence level just shock
i'm gonna make a few more of these make
them a little smaller more uniform and
move on whenever i make fritters i love
having like a saucy element to go along
with it to get started i just want to
chop some of the carrot tops oh it
smells so good it smells like you're
walking into a garden it's just like
carrot you know even if i had been given
pepper i think that would have been
helpful but
lemon juice
this is also going to be really nice to
like cut the like fattiness the richness
of the fritter and this is just a little
salt yeah
that's kind of cute i'm just going to
plate this which is incredibly easy i
think it looks like really cute very
creative you can do so much with so
little this is really cute appetizer set
i'm gonna finish up with the main course
okay so for my main dish it feels really
ambitious but i'm gonna try to make
pasta in a shrimp broto to start i have
to make the shrimp stock i'm going to
use these carrot tops which have like so
much flavor in them just add them right
to the water whenever i'm making shrimp
at home we always save the shells and
keep them in a bag in the freezer i'm
also going to use this lemon that i
zested before there's still a few peels
on here that i think i can get i'm gonna
add some salt because i don't have real
garlic i'm gonna add some of the garlic
powder
yeah now onto the shrimp i know this
sounds really weird but i actually love
peeling shrimp making stocks is such a
great way to use up what you have in
your pantry and in your fridge my
water's starting to simmer i've peeled
my shrimp so time to add the shells in
and this part is really fun because the
shells turn like bright pink pretty
quickly you can totally do this with
shrimp without the heads on but that's
just gonna add even more flavor isn't
that cool i'm gonna let this simmer and
move on to the pasta i've made pastas so
many times but i've never used aquafaba
and i'm really excited to see how it
turns out add some salt and then pour it
right in the middle and i'm going to add
a little bit of olive oil which is going
to keep it like really tender and add
like a great texture at this point i
would start kneading if it was with an
egg so i think i'll do the same when
you're making pasta it always feels
wrong you're like how can this become
pasta it does feel
different than pasta with an egg in it
this is a lot harder to knead i feel
like i could chuck it and it would like
kind of knock someone out i think this
is as good as it's gonna get i'm gonna
put some plastic wrap over it let it
hang out for 30 minutes an hour
confidence level five my dough's been
resting and it actually looks a lot
better basically it looks exactly how i
want it to just a shock now if you're
making homemade pasta you want to make
sure that whatever dough you're not
using you are keeping sealed when you're
making pasta start on the widest setting
i like to go through a few times on each
setting i feel like confidence level now
is like 6.5 one more just to like get it
really perfect i can't believe it it
looks beautiful i'm so impressed i'm
just going to add a little bit of flour
and cut it by hand i think i'm going to
do papardelle type length that feels
right ah
it's so good the day has taken at 180.
perfect wow i'm gonna let this pasta
hang out can kind of like dry out a
little and then move on so now i'm gonna
cook my shrimp i strained this shrimp
stock i'm gonna poach the shrimp in the
stock since the stock is heated up i'm
just gonna add the shrimp right in
poaching is a really nice way to cook
shrimp i mean look how fast it goes it's
already starting to turn pink i'm just
gonna let that cook for another minute
looking really good shrimp is done i'm
gonna keep the broth just off to the
side my shrimp are ready to go and now
all i have to do is boil the pasta it's
going to add a little bit more salt to
it and cook the pasta when you're making
homemade pasta the joy is that it cooks
really quickly just want to kind of
gently twirl it just so it doesn't stick
together basically when it starts to
float and come to the top you're done oh
the texture is a little weird
i don't love it it doesn't really taste
like pasta i don't know guys it's kind
of sticking together let me add a few
shrimp maybe that'll salvage i think for
the ingredients i have i've done the
best i can i just want to add a little
of the broth this is going to help i
think maybe a little olive oil a little
salt and then i thought i would just put
some of the carrot top greens on just
for a little contrast there's nothing
else i can do i'm going to get the other
two courses and it's time for katie and
betsy to taste them fingers crossed
betsy katie yes i have made you a
three-course meal using only five
ingredients as you know we've been
watching it yeah we've been impressed
exceeded expectations it kind of looks
like a full meal should we try the
appetizer first chickpea cornflake
carrot fritters
nice crunch
i really like that it's shockingly good
i
really really like this main course i'm
nervous about this one i know you were
skeptical but i'm actually excited okay
cheers
oh my god that's a little a wee bit
salty i think the shrimp are cooked
perfectly and i don't mind the shrimp
stock i find that the texture of the
noodles to be hard very excited for
dessert cheers
oh this is shockingly good it's like
foamy it's crunchy the corn flakes
really worked out only five ingredients
in a three-course meal i'm impressed
when you made pasta one thing is for
sure i cannot believe that you did this
i feel really proud but if you want more
recipes kind of like this i have a
cookbook coming out april 19th and it's
all about this very thing making the
most of your ingredients in ways that
are really inspiring and delicious and
we're so proud of you i love that you
can pre-order in the link below and if
you want to see me do a challenge like
this again let us know and go read your
cookbook to us
[Music]
[Music]